hello i'm kenneth branagh and i'm  talking belfast with the academy from  this period most certainly the movies in  the film are ones that had a big big  impact whether it was because  raquel welch in a million years bc was  was sort of dazzlingly arresting or  chili chili bang bang where not only did  you have amazing color but you had a  a very  unforgettable figure in the child  catcher it was those big immersive ones  at that time that took us to epic  landscapes but on television that's  where the western shane although that  didn't make it into the movie was uh a  big influence in our villain billy  clanton uh we have a great actor colin  morgan who looks a lot like jack palance  in shade with the raven black hair and  the you know the lean and hungry look